campagne nom féminin qui en langage
militaire désigne un ensemble
d'opérations menées sur un terrain
déterminé en matière d'élection c'est un
peu comme à la guerre une vingtaine et
efficace que si l'on est bien armé la
question donc d'y aller la fleur au
fusil
d'autant plus que le terrain d'action
est particulièrement miné leurs règles
précises pour les municipales la
campagne électorale a officiellement
commencé le 10 mars à partir de cette
date taïaut taïaut tous à cheval
la bagarre va s'accélère tracts réunions
publiques médias nés tous les coups ne
sont pas permis
interdit de coller ses affiches
n'importe où un seul porte drapeau le
célèbre panneau électoral les médias ces
héros des temps modernes doivent
contacter veiller à des temps de parole
équitable pour tous les candidats et
leurs soutiens interdit d'essayer de
rameuter la cavalerie à beerse en
distribuant des tracts de la veille et
le jour du scrutin
pendant deux jours ci drapeau côté
numéraire interdit de faire fondre
l'argenterie ou de vendre les membres du
musée municipal les candidats dans les
communes de plus de 9000 habitants ont
l'obligation d'avoir un compte de
campagne
mais quel que soit celui qui aura gagné
les clés de la ville au final c'est le
même régime il faudra laisser la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et des financements politiques
si si ça existe vérifiez que recettes et
dépenses sont bien en règle pourquoi
vous le disais on part en campagne la
fleur au fusil